[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen viel
Fußball hat gleich Norbert Lehmann für
Sie einen schönen guten Abend von mir
und der CDU-Chef löst große Empörung aus
ein sommerinterview halt nach was
Friedrich Merz über den Umgang mit der
AFD gesagt hat bringt die Union in
Wallung
wenn der Urlaub ein Raub der Flammen
wird Touristen und Einheimische fliehen
vor den Bränden auf Rhodos und Kopf
so ganz weitergehen mit einem Kantersieg
startet das deutsche Team in die Frauen
wählen
CDU-Chef Merz wird aus den eigenen
unionsreihen und der Ampelkoalition
scharf kritisiert März hatte sich im ZDF
sommerinterview zu einer möglichen
Zusammenarbeit seiner Partei mit der AFD
auf kommunaler Ebene geäußert führende
CDU-Politiker und Politikerinnen und
auch CSU-Chef Söder distanzieren sich
davon März versuchte Debatte einzufangen
Patricia Wiedemeier
eigentlich war die Linie der Union
bisher klar keine Zusammenarbeit mit der
AFD doch gestern in Berlin direkt
sommerinterview schließt CDU-Chef Merz
Kontakte auf lokaler Ebene plötzlich
nicht mehr aus
wir sind doch selbstverständlich
verpflichtet demokratische Wahlen zu
akzeptieren und wenn dort das noch mal
ein Landrat ein Bürgermeister gewählt
wird der der AFD angehört ist es
selbstverständlich dass man nach Wegen
sucht wie man dann in dieser Stadt
weiter arbeiten kann es folgt heftige
Kritik auch aus den eigenen Reihen so
wie man es selten bisher erlebt hat
heute morgen dann rudert mehr zurück und
twittert es wird auch auf kommunaler
Ebene keine Zusammenarbeit der CDU mit
der AFD geben doch der Satz war gesagt
die Reaktion auch von der
Schwesterpartei CSU lässt nicht lange
auf sich warten wir sind ganz klar gegen
jede Form der Kooperation mit der AFD
egal ob auf europäischer Bundes auf
Landes oder darf kommunale Ebene ein
nein heißt ein Nein für die CDU Hessen
kann ich sehr klar sagen dass die
Brandmauer ganz klar steht wir arbeiten
mit dieser Partei nicht zusammen für die
SPD sind die Aussagen von März ein
Tabubruch das Netz ist voll mit Tweets
von CDU-Abgeordneten vom Regierenden
Bürgermeister von Berlin vom Chef des
arbeitnehmerflügels von Abgeordneten und
vielen anderen mehr die empört sind die
auf die Beschlusslage der CDU verweisen
Herr Merz ist offensichtlich König ohne
Land eine unnötige Debatte man müsste
sich eher um die Probleme der Menschen
kümmern so der Innenminister aus NRW
schlimmer ist die Zahlen der AFD steigen
immer mehr an ich glaube nicht dass die
meisten Wählerinnen und Wähler
rechtsradikale oder rechtsextremen sind
sondern die sind unzufrieden aus
unterschiedlichen Gründen und darum
müssen wir uns kümmern nach großer
Empörung versucht die CDU nun die
Debatte wieder einzufangen doch
Friedrich Merz betonte heute am späten
Nachmittag dann er habe von dem was er
hier gestern gesagt habe doch nicht
zurückzunehmen
also ein ziemliches hin und her von März
statt unter labenergy wie weit geht die
Kritik am CDU-Chef also so laut wie
heute war sie bisher noch nie das muss
man schon sagen und die Kritik kommt
nicht nur von den beiden Wahlkämpfern in
Bayern und den Hessen sondern die ist
sehr breit gestreut man hört Stimmen aus
dem Bundesvorstand man hört Stimmen von
Landesebene und das geht runter bis zu
den Kommunen und bis zur Basis und alle
distanzieren sich sehr deutlich vom
Parteichef das ist sehr ungewöhnlich für
die CDU das muss man sagen und es ist
ein Zeichen dafür dass Friedrich Merz
hier zwei große offene Baustellen immer
noch hat in der Partei die er eigentlich
zügig bearbeiten wollte nachdem er
parteiche wurde nämlich zum einen den
Richtungsstreit beizulegen in der Partei
und zum anderen auch wieder für ein
klares konservatives Profil zu sorgen
das hatten sich viele von ihm erhofft
das hat er jetzt mit den Äußerungen in
der vergangenen Wochen gerade nicht
geschafft sondern stattdessen hat er
auch in der eigenen Partei für
Verwirrung gesorgt dass er zum Beispiel
die Grünen zum Hauptgegner
gemacht hat mit einem Satz als er von
der CDU als Alternative für Deutschland
nur mit Substanz gesprochen hat und
jetzt eben die missglückte Äußerung zum
zur Brandmauer das alles ruft eben
scharfe Kritik vor aus eigenen Reihen
Friedrich Merz selbst versucht das jetzt
wieder einzufangen auch indem er darauf
hingewiesen hat dass die öffentliche
Debatte auf Twitter nur der CDU schade
das ist so etwas wie ein Machtwort das
aber auch sprechen muss wenn er seine
Autorität verteidigen will vielen Dank
für diese Einschätzung
und wir schauen nach Israel am
Nachmittag wurde dort ein Kernstück der
umstrittenen Justizreform verabschiedet
mit den Stimmen der Koalition trotz
massiver Proteste erhält die Regierung
vom Ministerpräsidenten italiano also an
der reformfest mit der heute
beschlossenen Klausel hat das Oberste
Gericht nicht mehr die Möglichkeit
Entscheidungen der Regierung als
unangemessen zu kippen die Opposition
sieht Israels Demokratien gefahren
tausende blockierten am Morgen die
Zufahrt zum israelischen Parlament die
kneset Wasserwerfer Festnahmen am
Nachmittag ging es drinnen dann ganz
schnell mit ihrer Mehrheit beschloss die
rechts religiöse Koalition von Benjamin
netanjaro die angemessenheitsklausel
abzuschaffen
wir haben ein historischen ersten
Schritt gemacht um das Justizsystem zu
korrigieren und der Regierung und der
Knesset macht wiederzugeben die ihr über
Jahre genommen wurde
für die Opposition eine Aushebelung der
Gewaltenteilung geschlossen verließen
sie die Knesset vor der letzten Lesung
Schande riefen sie Schande inzwischen
klagen sie gegen die Abschaffung des
Gesetzes der Oppositionsführer spricht
von einem schwarzen Tag für die
Demokratie
heute ist ein trauriger Tag ein Tag an
dem der Tempel zerstört wurde diese
extreme Regierung feiert den Tag an dem
sie alles was uns verbunden hat in den
Mülleimer der Geschichte geworfen
währenddessen gehen die Demonstrationen
weiter denn der erste Teil der
sogenannten Justizreform sieht vor den
Gerichten die Möglichkeit zu nehmen
Entscheidungen der Regierung zu kippen
wenn diese nicht angemessen erscheinen
das wollen sie nicht zulassen
ich denke die Demonstrationen werden
noch intensiver ich hoffe nicht dass es
zu Gewalt kommt
[Musik]
ich habe Angst mein Land verliert nach
und nach alles was die Demokratie
bewahren könnte und ich habe Angst
ich werde weiter protestieren wir haben
keine andere Chance das ist der eine Ort
den wir haben die Alternative ist
ein historischer Tag in Israel fest
steht die Demokratie im Land ist
erschüttert
gehen wir direkt zu Stefanie gagor
Stefanie seit Monaten gibt es diese
Massenproteste wir haben eben gerade
schon ein paar Stimmen gehört von den
Demonstrierenden
nun da gehen die meisten von hier aus
zumindest heute haben sie sich
ausgeweitet von Jerusalem zurück nach
Tel Aviv wir sind teilweise Straßen
gesperrt und die meisten die ich heute
getroffen haben haben gesagt sie werden
weitermachen ja klar die Frage ist auch
was passiert mit den angekündigten
Arbeitsniederlegungen von Ärzten von
Geschäftsleuten von Gewerkschaften was
macht der Chef der Börse der sich
dagegen ausgesprochen hat was machen die
Chef der ehemaligen Geschäftsjahr
Geheimdienstes und was passiert mit dem
Militär viele viele servisten haben ja
gesagt sie würden dann nicht mehr dienen
und das ist in der Tat einmalig in der
Geschichte von Israel einem Land das
doch geschlossen nach außen auftreten
sollte diese
polyetarisierung der der der das
Militärs und viele Israelis haben nun
Angst vor einem Bürgerkrieg äh ein
Bekannter Fernsehkanal hat ein Umfrage
gemacht 67% sagen Sie haben dafür Angst
und manche überlegen das Land zu
verlassen es werden sicherlich sehr
schwierige
Frage und ich hoffe dass es friedlich
bleibt Dankeschön Stefanie garasch
im Süden Europas ist es weiter
überwiegend trocken und heiß besonders
in Griechenland machen Einheimischen und
urlauern nicht nur die hohen
Temperaturen zu schaffen sondern vor
allem die Flächenbrände die sich weiter
ausbreiten
auf Korfu der Insel und weiten Teil des
Festlands gibt es große Feuer besonders
dramatisch bleibt die Lage auf Rhodos
auf der Karte sieht man wie die
brandgebiete die Insel fast
durchschneiden und Satellitenaufnahmen
zeigen dass auch der Rauch zunehmend zum
Problem wird Alexandra Vacano
es brennt und brennt es ist bereits der
siebte Tag des Feuers auf Rhodos der
Wind die Hitze sie machen den Kampf
gegen die Flammen schier endlos
in ihrer Verzweiflung holen Einwohner
jetzt schon selbst Wasser aus dem Meer
um löschen zu können es gäbe keine
Kontrolle über das Feuer sagen sie
unsere Häuser werden vielleicht morgen
nicht mehr da sein vielleicht brennen
Sie jetzt wir wissen nicht was wir tun
sollen
wir brauchen Hilfe schicken sie uns
Hilfe von überall her heute kam
Feuerwehrleute aus Rumänien
Löschflugzeuge und Hubschrauber aus
Frankreich Kroatien oder der Türkei sind
schon im Einsatz in Griechenland weg von
den Flammen weg von der Insel einige
Touristen sind kilometerweit zum
Flughafen von Rhodos gelaufen haben ihre
Koffer zurückgelassen und erzählen vom
Chaos bei der Evakuierung
die einzige Hilfe die wir erhalten haben
kam von den Griechen wir haben keine
Hilfe von britischen Reiseveranstaltern
oder Behörden erhalten überhaupt keine
Hilfe Andrea Klez und ihr Mann haben
sich auf eigene Faust aufgemacht sind
mit dem Taxi zum Flughafen im Prinzip
haben wir
es irgendwie wir haben dann rüber
gebrüllt was los ist und die haben
gesagt alle weg hier werden evakuiert
und in unserem Hotel ist nichts passiert
und für die die erstmal in Turnhallen
der Insel untergekommen sind für sie
gibt es von den Einheimischen Wasser
Matratzen oder Donuts in dieser
Situation ein kleiner Lichtblick
und am Flughafen von Rhodos steht für
uns Andreas Postel wie ist die Lage
Moment Andreas
nachdem sich hier in den vergangenen 48
Stunden am Flughafen chaotische Szenen
abgespielt haben sind heute den ganzen
Tag über Flugzeuge gestartet um
Touristen nach Hause zurückzufliegen
etwa 3000 in den seit gestern
ausgeflogen worden und heute abend gehen
Maschinen ab nach Berlin nach Frankfurt
nach Düsseldorf und Dortmund also es
werden Touristen ausgeflogen aber es
müssen eben auch viele tausende
wahrscheinlich eine weitere Nacht in
Notunterkünften hier auf der Insel
verbringen oder aber sie profitieren von
der großen griechischen Gastfreundschaft
viele haben Notunterkünfte bei privaten
Leuten gefunden Aufnahme privat gefunden
und wurden versorgt mit dem Nötigsten
mit Wasser mit zu essen also auch das
gibt es hier aber insgesamt ist es jetzt
schon ein schwerer Schlag für die Insel
für die Einheimischen vor allen Dingen
den Rhodos lebt von Tourismus und auch
wenn Rhodos selbst weiten Teilen nicht
von den brennenden betroffen ist ist es
doch klar dass er alle von diesen
dramatischen Brandgeschehen hier in
Mitleidenschaft gezogen werden es brennt
aktuell in südostenlandes aktuell hat
uns der Katastrophenschutz mit geteilt
das weitere drei Ortschaften evakuiert
werden mussten vorsorglich wegen der
brennende die auch nach sechs Tagen
immer noch nicht und der Kontrolle
gebracht werden konnten trotz
internationaler Hilfe es gilt ja also
auf Rhodos weiterhin die höchste
brandverfahren
danke schön
um mehrzulage in Griechenland sehen Sie
in einem zdf-spezial direkt nach diesen
heute Nachrichten
auch nigerien wüten Waldbrände 25
Menschen kam dabei heute ums Leben es
brennt an mehreren Stellen des Landes an
der Mittelmeerküste und an einem
bergigen Gebiet im Landesinneren
7.500 Feuerwehrleute und armeeinheiten
sind im Einsatz viele Menschen mussten
aus den gefährdeten Orten herausgebracht
werden unter den Opfern sind 10 Soldaten
die die Löschmannschaften unterstützt
haben
zum ukrainekrieg da greift Russland
zurzeit vermehrt Ziele entlang der Donau
an die Wasserstraße ist nun wichtiger
geworden als exportweg für ukrainisches
Getreide nach dem Ende des Schwarzen
Meer getreideabkommens ihrerseits hat
die Ukraine offenbar wieder Moskau
geschossen zwei Gebäude wurden
beschädigt als die russische Luft Abwehr
nach eigenen Angaben zwei
drohnenabschoss
auch auf der von Russland besetzten
Halbinsel Krim gab es Drohnenangriffe
der Ukraine dort wurde unter anderem ein
Waffendepot getroffen
Spanien steht nach der Wahl gestern vor
einem politischen Patt im Parlament
Ministerpräsident Petrus Sanchez von den
Sozialisten hat 122 der 350 Sitze
errungen sein Kontrahent Alberto fächo
von der konservativen Volkspartei PP
gewann deutlich Stimmen hinzu und kommt
auf 136 Sitze
beide haben zwar mögliche
Koalitionspartner können aber keine
absolute Mehrheit im Parlament hinter
sich bringen Thomas Walde berichtet
der Tag nach der Wahl bringt
drahtlosigkeit Instabilität die
Regierung hängt in der Luft niemand kann
sagen wer nun regieren wird einer Tat am
Abend zuvor so als wäre er das Albert
und nun jetzt Fero ließ sich von seiner
Volkspartei Pipi feiern und beanspruchte
Ministerpräsident zu werden
ich will versuchen unser Land gemäß dem
Wahlergebnis dem Wahlsieg zu regieren
hat keine Mehrheit im Parlament der
mögliche Koalitionspartner verlor
stimmen die republikanische Brandmauer
gegen die Rechtsaußen hielt VOX schäumte
Petrus kann selbst als Wahl Verlierer
eine Amtseinführung blockieren und
schlimmer noch Petrus Sanchez könnte
sogar mit Unterstützung von Kommunisten
separatistischen und Terroristen
wiedergewählt werden
tatsächlich wurde der bisherige
Regierungschef Petrus Sanchez heute von
seinen Sozialisten wie ein Gewinner
gefeiert Sanchez Taktik Angst zu schüren
vor einem Rechtsruck verhinderte dass er
sein Amt sofort verloren
Spanien und alle seine Bürger die zur
Wahl gegangen sind haben sich klar
ausgedrückt der Block des Rückschritts
der alle Fortschritte die wir in den
letzten vier Jahren gemacht haben
rückgängig machen wollte ist gescheitert
die Spanier haben gesagt was sie wollen
oder besser sie haben gesagt was sie
nicht wollen nun müssen die gewählten
nur noch daraus eine Regierung machen
Madrid ist für uns Anna Warsberg anna
steht Spanien jetzt vor einer langen
politischen Hängepartie
durchaus davon auszugehen dass ich noch
lange hinziehen wird bis es hier zu
einer Regierungsbildung in Spanien kommt
und das in dem Land das seit ersten Juli
für sechs Monate die
EU-Ratspräsidentschaft in der hat jetzt
geht es darum wie rauskommen aus dieser
partsituation das ist nichts Neues für
Spanien das gab es hier schon mal der
konservative sejo hat das Problem dass
er VOX die extremen Rechten braucht um
eine rechte Regierung zu bilden um eine
Mehrheit zu bekommen aber keine anderen
Parteien mit VOX zusammenarbeiten
möchten Petrus Sanchez hat er mehr
Möglichkeiten er könnte mit den
kleineren Splitterparteien zusammen
gehen und hat jetzt auch heute schon
Abgeordnete von seinem bisherigen linken
Koalitionspartner losgeschickt um
Gespräche erste Gespräche mit den
katalanischen Separatisten zu führen
wenn es jetzt keinen der beiden
Parteichefs gelingt erfolgreiche
Gespräche zu führen dann steht Spanien
wohl eine Neuwahl bevor dankeschön
die Ungleichheit in Deutschland wächst
immer weiter sagt linken Parteichef
Schirdewahn deshalb müsste der
Sozialstaat armutsfest gemacht werden
dazu haben die Linken ihre Pläne für
mehr soziale Gerechtigkeit vorgelegt
eine zentrale Forderung ein gesetzlicher
automatischer Inflationsausgleich für
alle Löhne und Gehälter damit würden
Reallohnverluste vermieden
für 6 €, die Preise sind gestiegen die
Inflationsrate ist weiter hoch da
müssten Löhne und Gehälter mitziehen und
zwar automatisch per Gesetz fordert die
Partei DIE LINKE
vor allen Dingen beruhigt dass die
Menschen wenn sie wissen jedes Jahr
kriegen sie die Erhöhung der Inflation
ausgeglichen durch eine entsprechende
Steigerung ihrer Löhne und Gehälter ein
sogenannter indexlohn den es schon in
einigen europäischen Ländern gibt bei
Beschäftigten kommt die Idee überwiegend
gut an ja finde ich richtig weil
es wird ja auch alles teurer und dann
sollten auch die Löhne dementsprechend
angepasst werden beim Index Lohn wird
meist ein Verbraucherpreisindex zugrunde
gelegt also bestimmte Waren und
Dienstleistungen das Problem in der
aktuellen Situation ist dass die
Verbraucherpreise stärker gestiegen sind
als die Preise der Unternehmen in
Deutschland und dann würden die
Lohnsteigerungen zu hoch ausfallen und
dann gäbe es eine große Gefahr von
beschäftigungsverlusten
also Arbeitsplätze in Gefahr durch zu
hohe Lohnkosten für die Unternehmen Pro
und Contra index-
und jetzt kommen wir zur
Fußballweltmeisterschaft denn das war ja
wirklich ein Traum statt für die
deutschen Frauen und das allen Unken
rufen zum Trotz das DFB-Team hoch
motiviert souverän und mit großer
Spielfreude 6 zu 0 hieß es am Ende gegen
tapfere WM aus Marokko der bislang
höchste Sieg bei dieser
Weltmeisterschaft
wenn es Geld scheinen die deutschen
Frauen voll da zu sein Verteidigerin
Katrin Henrich als flankengeberin und
Alexandra Popp nach elf Minuten die
Führung durch die Kapitäne Pop darf ihre
besondere jubel-geste dann auch nach 39
Minuten zeigen das 2:0 ein Kopfball der
allen physikalischen Gesetzen zu
widersprechen scheint
das Team aus der Kabine gerade mal 21
Sekunden nach wieder Anpfiff belohnt
sich Clara Bühl für ein starkes Spiel
selbstsicher geworden setzt man die
Marokkanerinnen weiter unter Druck den
92 der Weltrangliste unterlaufen nun
auch noch zwei Eigentore das Spiel Mitte
der zweiten Halbzeit längst entschieden
auch die einwechselspielerinnen zeigen
bis leer Schüler zum 6:0 entstand das
deutsche Team hat einen perfekten
Turnier statt hingelegt und die Besucher
in Melbourne mit seiner Spielfreude
angesteckt
[Musik]
die geschlossene Teamleistung lässt
hoffen für das zweite Gruppenspiel am
Sonntag gegen Kolumbien
[Musik]
im ersten Spiel des Tages bezwang
Italien Argentinien knapp mit 1:0 erst
in der 87 minute fiel der
spielentscheidende Treffer die zuvor
eingewechselte Christiana girelli traf
aus 11 Metern per Kopf ein sehenswertes
Tor und ein glücklicher italienischer
Sieg
sowas von souverän dagegen der Auftritt
der Brasilianerin 4:0 gegen Panama
spielerischer Höhepunkt die
ballstaffette zum 13.0 in der 48 Minute
blitzschnell und technisch perfekt über
fünf Stationen am Ende versenkt bia
zanerato den Ball im Netz ja wahrlich
brasilianisch
bei der Schwimm-WM in Fukuoka ist einer
Elend letztes Jahr noch werden zweite
schon im Vorlauf über 100 m Brust
ausgeschieden ins Finale schaffen des
Lukas Matzerath in derselben Disziplin
und Angelina Köhler über 100 Meter
Schmetterling bei der erreichten Rang
fünft
erster deutscher Erfolg bei der
diesjährigen Tour de France der Frauen
Liane Lippert gewann völlig überraschend
die zweite Etappe von Clement nach
moriac die 25-Jährige setzte sich im
Massen Sprint nach 152 km vor der
Bergrennen Lotto durch die das Gelbe
Trikot verteidigen konnte
den deutschen Männern bei dieser tote
Frau sind in diesem Jahr verwehrt bitte
wechselhafte Aussichten für die ganze
Woche kommen gleich von Katja Hornbach
immer wieder gibt es Schauer und
Gewitter zwischendurch auch Sonnenschein
das heute journal läuft um 21 Uhr mit
Dunja Hayali auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend das wird eine wechselhafte
wetterwoche denn von Westen ziehen immer
wieder Schauer und Gewitter über uns
hinweg zwischendurch sehen sie aber auch
mal die Sonne das war auch heute so da
ging es mit den Gewittern in
Baden-Württemberg und Bayern los später
dann aber auch in Sachsen in
Nordrhein-Westfalen die Gewitter zogen
über Niedersachsen über Brandenburg über
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und auch entlang
der Nordseeküste entwickelten sich hier
gewittrige Regenschauer diese Gewitter
ziehen jetzt am Abend weiter ostwärts
und in der zweiten Nachthälfte verlassen
Sie uns dann mehr und mehr Richtung Pool
an den Alpen gibt's da neue kräftige
Gewitter das sind auch gewittrige
Regenschauer bei einem Wind aus
westlichen bis nordwestlichen Richtungen
so sinken die Temperaturen auf 16 Grad
z.B hier Richtung Lausitz und bis zehn
Grad im Oldenburger Münsterland und
morgen liegen die Höchsttemperaturen bei
nur 16 Grad in der Eifel oder im
Hunsrück und maximal 23 Grad in Berlin
Brandenburg und auch im östlichen
Sachsen
im Süden gibt es morgen weitere
Regenfälle gewittrig sind die durchsetzt
freundlicher sieht es aus zwischen
Hannover Schwerin und Berlin da zeigt
sich die Sonne der Mittwoch sieht ganz
ähnlich aus der Donnerstag wird im Süden
etwas ruhiger und der Freitag von Westen
wärmer guten Abend